we may be taught to avoid these
behaviors from an early age but numerous
studies show there are actually benefits
to committing the seven deadly sins who
doesn't enjoy some lazy time in cities
where people walk slower there are more
displays of helpful behavior and lower
risk of death and coronary heart disease
and studies have found that adults who
take naps live longer fried is the
primary emotion that affects our
self-esteem when people are praised they
spend more time on things they're good
at pride also reinforces behaviors like
altruism
and achievement experiencing an
accepting wrath is key to our mental
health anger can spur positive social
revolutions like civil rights movements
expressing anger to another person can
serve as an incentive them to treat you
better
greed is a powerful motivator and makes
you more self-reliant studies show that
when communities are hierarchically
structured whether among humans or
animals those at the top tend to make
more of an effort in the interests of
the group and those at the bottom
biologically you need to crave food so
you don't starve to death when you eat
sweet or fatty foods with high calories
the pleasure centers of your brain are
activated the body also releases opioids
which help control pain Envy makes us
more driven creative and ultimately
happier one study revealed that envy
motivates students to spend more time on
schoolwork and perform better on certain
tests lust is a crucial mechanism for
encouraging reproduction sex boosts your
immune system sexually active people
take fewer sick days and non sexually
active people it also releases the
hormone oxytocin which helps us be more
accepting of others and create trust and
intimacy sinning doesn't sound so bad
now does it